we know you're just stockpiling it in
your garage like an episode of Preppers
or maybe you're popping them like M&Ms
the dinner-table and really your union
birth control but your stuff in a napkin
like broccoli and feeding it to the dog
and they're wondering my fluffy is
lactating
let's get to one thing here Amy Schumer
released a sketch on Comedy Central did
I already answer that I don't think
she's funny now I don't know sometimes
it's tough to know what's on air and
what's off air Amy Schumer and I have
had our run-ins and I respect immensely
what she has accomplished as a stand-up
comedian I have too but she's crossing
over into territory I mean you don't
want to perpetuate rape culture at all
let's roll the clip of the of the of the
sketch where's the doctor
we're your doctor no you're a bunch of
congressmen I recognize you I just need
to get my annual pap smear you do any of
you any medical training we're the House
Committee on women's health so I think
we have a better idea than a bunch of
science' nurdles
you mean doctors let's begin when was
the date of your last lady kurz two
weeks ago if you mean my period the
argument here if you watch the whole
sketches from Amy Schumer is Congress
being in your ob/gyn right that they
will they have their hands over women's
bodies the message is pretty clear right
you saw that not get your I did but the
message is a bunch of men privileged men
getting to decide your health care
getting up in your vajayjay right I
don't know why Lord
could you make a segment more than the
jingo your your your vajazzled vajazzled
that's a new one that was bedazzled and
they had those rhinestones for the
nether regions okay so Amy Schumer
all right let's time to do this here
sorry it's come to this I've tried to be
I try and cut a wide swath for comedians
and give them a little bit of
forgiveness why would it be that men in
Congress get to determine what kind of
birth control or what kind of health
care services you get could it possibly
be because of social justice warrior
wenches like you and Sandra Fluke and
Lena Dunham demanded through Congress
and stood before the house and stood the
grand standard and filibustered
obviously that didn't really happen but
they grande sin and they went forward
demand
free birth control demanding that the
taxpayer subsidized it guess what when
you demand that I pay for your birth
control
you've now granted that authority to the
government I'm paying for birth control
with my insurance because it's mandated
I'll never use birth control I don't
even use condoms I've never used condoms
condoms are for losers listen if you use
condoms I have no respect for you you
are a man who has no self-respect you
take your chances and you roll the dice
as it goes with Amy Schumer obviously
I'm married so I'm not taking any
chances but my the case remains with Amy
Schumer and you're to think with Sandra
Fluke and Lena Dunham to listen and they
you were yelling this out at the UMass
thing I think the jigglypuff women's
reproductive rights and they want free
birth control okay you're not fooling
anybody with this all right the free
birth control you may convince some of
the gender queers and your pot-smoking
drum circle but none of us are buying it
that you required so much birth control
that you need me to assist in paying for
your birth control okay it's like that
drunk chick at the bar I have a bid on
this about Lena Dunham but it applies
here where they're sitting there that
it's it's the opposite of virtue
signaling they're trying to act like
they're so promiscuous and they're in
such demand it's like that one's like
okay no you're gonna say it was like
trainwreck it's like exactly who was in
line for this woman no who was exams in
line who was in line for this woman
well they're saying you're fine buzz
your girl here's some cab fare go home
right believe me you're as safe as
you're as safe as in your mother's arms
here and some of them listen you may
even try and fake them out and go Daniel
day-lewis and method act with it you may
even go to the store and buy the birth
control to try and convince people we
know you're just stockpiling it in your
garage like an episode of Preppers or
maybe you're popping them like M&Ms the
dinner table and really your birth
control put your stuff in a napkin like
broccoli and feeding it to the dog and
they're wondering why Fluffy's lactating
even though he's a male it's just
lactation and what is going on with the
dog no one is buying that you need that
birth control by the way this this
sketch was already done as an ad by the
same ad company has done Ted Cruz's Adam
Everitt Uncle Sam was Uncle Sam the lady
was up on the forceps giving birth and
this creepy Uncle Sam poster came in and
the whole ad was and was very
libertarian theme
get Uncle Sam out of your doctor's
office get Uncle Sam out of your bedroom
it was a common theme this was this was
long ago before Lena Dunham was trying
to take your gun before sorry Amy
Schumer was trying to take your guns
away or Lena Dunham was trying to write
B and an Origin yes it's completely
unavailable offensive and if you're
trying to bash Republicans Republicans
and conservatives were the one this
entire time saying no Amy Schumer no
Lena Dunham we don't want our hands in
your hoo-ha we don't want to have to pay
for your birth control we don't want to
have anything to do with your
reproductive rights all we want is for
you to pay for it on your own and when
Sandra Fluke refer when Rush Limbaugh
referred to Sandra Fluke as a [ __ ]
everyone got mad listen if you are
having so much sex that you can't afford
a 25 cent rubber at a truck stop if the
word [ __ ] doesn't apply to you it might
as well be wiped from the history of the
dictionary because it was designed for
[ __ ] like Sandra Fluke and Amy Schumer
and Lena Dunham is a slut-shaming send
your letters to our affiliates I don't
care I know our affiliates support us if
they drop us I don't care
we'll take this online you are an
unbelievable reprehensible [ __ ] role
model by the way Amy Schumer you're a
fat [ __ ] role model okay well I know
she's not claimed to be a role model but
let's just be honest here she got all
mad when that one was L something
referred to her as plus-sized her whole
you can't have it both ways you can't
demand that someone funds your personal
sexual escapades and then go oh my God
why should guys have and I should guys
have a say in my reproductive rights why
because you demanded it you gave them
that authority and it's the same thing
by the way with conservatives it's the
same thing with the alt-right and Trump
okay I understand that a lot of you are
mad with Barack Obama and so am i but it
doesn't mean that you want your guy to
do it and take more control you do not
want to give that much control with the
government because you do not get it
back you do not want to give the
government the authority to to to to
monitor you you do not want to give the
government the authority to force you to
pay for birth control or force you to
pay for high premium and health plans do
you not want the government to force you
to register your gun you don't want any
of those things and the problem here is
that both sides think there's some other
guy who
did like a dictator this executive power
I want my guy to do it better no you
don't just like Amy Schumer was saying
oh yeah the religious right I will we
want we want reproductive rights we want
free birth control really you want to be
the world's most powerful genie and
everything that comes with it
boom shackles now these people get to
decide what your OBGYN treatment is like
just like in Canada
remember they mocked when conservatives
said death panels there's no such thing
as death panels it was a term coined to
create a visual picture what is a death
panel well let me talk about a death
panel is it's pretty similar to what
happened with my aunt with lung cancer
in Canada where they sat there in Canada
because their system is trained and they
can't afford it and they say okay she's
in Stage four she's older there might be
some experimental treatment that can
help her live longer very low success
rate but it's the only one that can work
but you know what it's not really worth
the price now you're gonna tell me that
I'm being inaccurate because I use the
term death panel it's not it's not a
legal term we get it we're talking about
the principle just like if you say an OB
GYN panel a birth control panel what
we're talking about is some Washington
DC bureaucrat because you've given them
the authority because you wanted free
crap who now gets to decide what you put
in your body and what's appropriate you
created that monster Amy Schumer Lena
Dunham all the strong women
is there any way is there anything we
cur than a woman who can't pay for her
own stuff and it's trying the tenant
woman well that's great for like a bus
right no for me vagina feels I don't
think that's a technical term well you
say death panels still I think that's
more accurate than vagina pills this
clip it's taken from the full-length
podcast every week you can click that
box down below to watch the full free
video casts or subscribe on iTunes to
watch them they go click my face to go
to ladder with writer comm where we
right plenty of articles columns and
upset those who are easily triggered or
click below me there's some other video
down there I don't know what it is yet
not gay Jarrod is going to toss it's
probably going to be something ambiguous
but uncomfortable